one of three ex orioles who have been
traded to the angels in the last
two seasons and this is alex cobb
who was traded in the offseason for
jamai jones
now there's the numbers on the year five
and three with a 5.09 era strikeouts are
up for him
[Applause]
mullins he threw in three split-fingered
fastballs in a row he leads the american
league
cedric does with 99 hits one out
another really good sequence by alex
kopp
gets a chase at an elevated fastball 94
miles an hour
back-to-back strikeouts to open bouncing
ball
right around the bag both defenders come
together david fletcher
with the bare-handed running play
base is full for the halos he's giving
up a single to fletcher
walks to ohtani and rendon right out of
the gate and jorge lopez
finds himself in a tough spot in his
first innings basis
full for the halos walsh very good with
the bases loaded this year 429 including
a grand slam remember that one
walsh on the ground back behind the bag
it's bobbled
everybody's safe the angels lead one to
nothing
and now the goose bases remain full for
gosselin
he rolls that one to the right side it's
gonna be tough to turn two they're not
able to do it and a good thing did
happen
he made contact shot it toward a hole
and it's two to nothing
there's the ground ball to shortstop can
the orioles get two a bobble from ureas
but they turn it anyway six four three
to get out of the inning with only two
runs of crops
that strike three outside corner little
comebacker
at six up six down for alex cobb
he leads him in steals with 12. iglesia
is not going this time
and rangifo is the first strikeout
victim tonight for jorge lopez
juan lagares 32 year old veteran
he drives that one that big man into the
gap and left center field it's down
up against the wall they're gonna send a
glaciers come on down says coach
butterfield
he will oblige he will score standing up
juan lagares with the double three
nothing angels
moving to third on the ground out will
be lagarus
here's shohei now did they pitch the
show hey here if they do pitch to him i
expect shohei to be ready on the first
pitch
they're gonna put him on we thought this
was gonna happen real soon and it's
already happening now
i think it's just the tip of the iceberg
oreos a little something brewing here
first and third nobody out the top of
third
and papa lake of the tying run out of
the stretch
a ground ball on 3-1 to third random
will go to second
fletcher to first nearly turned it but
veleka
is safe and he brings a run home laba
crosses to make it three one
there's a breaking ball and a good one
stassi down on the curve
third strikeout for lopez i'd love to
get a ground ball in the infield to see
if he can get two with it
he did fletch backhanded flint
turn double play good call my friend
like a true sinker ball or wood you
called it i love that ground ball laps a
great turn fletch
glaciers to walsh finish up the inning
shohei will lead it off the spotlight on
this man 30 and 10 before the break
walked unintentionally and scored then
intentionally
the 2-0 ohtani on the ground this time
not on top of that baseball and they get
shohei this time
and he has struck out again 95 up and in
from jorge
lopez strikeout number four
ball strikes that one lost struck toward
the bullpen
off the wall on the move jared eases
into second with a couple of bases
and for walsh that's 21 doubles on the
year that ball was
crushed so here is gosselin who has been
on base a couple of times
the goose lines it into left field for a
base hit
walsh will come around to score the
goose is loose
it's four to one
[Applause]
iglesias smacks a ground ball to the
leica the orioles are out of the inning
pleco strands a couple
one's rolled to iglesias comes around it
uses the grass and the grass was good to
win
plus that first baseman we always talk
about not only he out early
doing ground balls but must be working
on his yoga you bad that's a stretch by
walsh
what a play by iglesias that ball was
scolded
by the leica you know the backhand
knows he's got to be quick the one hop
skip the stretch
gets him at first what a play by both
iglesias
and jared walsh
you wonder if they're going to get a
chance to swing the bat here again
they're walking him again
we talked a little bit about the berry
bomb stream mike trout was getting that
treatment for a long time as well
well you can't blame them at all as much
damage as shohei has done
it's a tough pitch though now 2-0
on the ground again fletcher they're
gonna have to hurry on the first double
play
not sure if that might be the end of the
night for a cop if it is
job well done we'll see if he's back to
pitch in the
top of the eighth
agar is to center mullen's a long way
back he's got room and the inning is
over
exhale bases left loaded
orioles within three going to the eighth
that's great pitch wow he throws him
inside corner that's strike three
greg maddox would be proud of that pitch
this is wonderful
shohei ohtani has been walked three
times
shohei hits it a mile high to right
field
oh my goodness he dismissed that boy did
he dismiss that
one out to go to an angels victory
high pop up easy chance for laguaris
the halo shines bright again tonight the
angels
are victorious over the orioles by a
score of 4-1 and my goodness
iglesias has been amazing of late this
time
the backside of alex cobb's incredible
outing